Good afternoon, Hollandwood Finance, this is Laura speaking, how can I help you?
Oh hello, I need to close an account please.
Okay, no problems. Can I just ask why? Is there a problem with the account?
It's actually my father's account, he just passed away so I'm just tying up all the accounts and things.
Oh I'm so sorry to hear that, of course. What's your name? What was your father's name?
My father's name was Pete Young, I've got the account number here if you need it.
Pete Young, oh yes please, what's the account number?
It's CF098127. I've got him here Pete Young. Okay then I can close that for you, I'm so sorry.
Is there anything else that I can do today?
What should I do? I think the balance is on empty, right?
There's nothing in it I'm afraid.
There's nothing to tie up there. Anything else I can do for you today? That's all closed for you now.
Okay, that's great, thank you so much for your help.
Okay then, good bye.
Thanks, bye.